nous allons aborder le thème de la
création d'entreprise puisque se tient
le 28 mai le 4e Forum la 4e édition
pardon du forum de la création
d'entreprise ce sera au théâtre de 50
ans en Yveline Jean-Luc merraud vous
êtes directeur de la maison d'entreprise
qui a l'initiative de ce forum bonsoir
bonsoir et à vos côté Anthony strcher
qui est co-dirigeant de la société hat+
PME et lauréa du prix de la jeune
entreprise lors de la dernière édition
bonsoir bonsoir alors jeanluc Merot
finalement quel est le but de ce forum
c'est d'informer sur la création
d'entreprise valoriser les jeunes
créateurs
oui un peu les deux c'est-à-dire que
c'est aussi l'occasion de de de mettre
en avant tous les acteurs économiques
qui qui agissent à un moment donné en
faveur de la création d'entreprise et
donc les les les valoriser euh euh
développer une véritable vitrine des
aides à la création d'entreprise et puis
permettre donc à l'ensemble des porteurs
de projets de notre bassin d'activité de
bénéficier de d'aide dans le lieu unique
et sur un ton relativement concentré
alors ça va s'organiser autour de trois
axes oui Absolum des exposants les
ateliers thématiques et puis la remise
de prix les exposants il y en a une
trentaine je pense voilà donc nous avons
une trentaine d'exposants donc qui
seront réunis au théâtre de de 50 an
livelg dans toute la journée du du mardi
et puis cette journée sera articulée
ponctuée d'un certain nombre d'ateliers
nous aurons six ateliers sur des thèmes
à la fois classique comme le financement
ou la les les quelques informations sur
les notions juridiques mais nous avons
voulu également cette année mettre
l'accent sur les thématique un peu plus
spécifique notamment la transmission
d'entreprise et puis un sujet qui euh
qui se développe notamment sur le le
territoire de saintantan VG que
l'économie sociale et solidaire donc
voilà des sujets divers et variés
qui absolument on a on a des demandes
qui sont de qui sont croissantes sur ces
sujetsl et on sait que l'économie
sociale et solidaire favorise notamment
l'embauche et par ces temps un peu
difficiles il est important de de ne pas
négliger cet aspect là des choses et
malgré ces temps difficil vous attendez
beaucoup de monde c'est toujours
difficile de d'avoir des estimations
sait que sur l'année sur l'édition
précédente on avait environ 6 à 7 100
personnes sur sa visiteur donc c'est
relativement conséquent sur un
territoire pour un territoire comme le
nôtre donc cette année on espère
effectivement avoir au moins autant de
de de visiteurs sur ce forum alors la
journée va se clôturer par la remise
donc des prix du concours de la création
et du développement de la jeune
entreprise c'est un concours qui a lieu
tous les 2 ans voilà donc c'est c'est à
distinguer quand même du de de la partie
forum mais c'est vrai qu'on profite de
cette journée pour pour valoriser les
lauréal donc ce concours a lieu tous les
2 ans sur le le bassin activité de 50 an
liveline donc qui rayonneent au-delà des
des SEP communes de 50 ans d'Eline et
donc nous profitons de de de la journée
du du du du du forum pardon pour euh
pour remettre les les prix à nous à nous
si lauréa et ça se passera en fin de
journée à 18h au cinéma UGC de de 50 en
livl les les prix à hauteur de 50000 €
voilà toujours dans dans un contexte de
de partenariat donc nous essayons de
mobiliser un certain nombre d'acteurs
pour que ces acteurs puissent B
contribuer de à leur manière au
développement économique du territoire
et donc on a un pot commun dans lequel
chacun abonde de différentes manières et
cette année on a réussi à mobiliser
environ une enveloppe de 500000 € de
prix donc ces 50000 € seront répartis
euh en fonction des des lauréat etell
seront donc remis le le mardi prochain
au cinéma UGC alors Antony strchard vous
avez gagné ce fameux prix dans la
catégorie Jeune Entreprise il y a 2 ans
euh donc vous votre entreprise c'est une
centrale d'achat pour les PME donc elle
permet de mutiltiliser les services
généraux pour TP PME donc finalement
pour diminuer les coûts voilà on va
faire simple on est une entreprise de
mutualisation d'achat qui permett aux
petites et moyennes entreprises de
bénéficier de tarifs qui ne peuvent pas
avoir seuls par l'effet de volume
l'effet de masse qui sera normalement
réservé au très grandes entrepris qui
est toujours classiquement réservé au
grand groupes hein vous appelez 26 c'est
plus facile de négocier face à un
fournisseur donc aujourd'hui on fait la
même chose pour les TPE et PME parce que
faut le rappeler quand même c'est à peu
près quasiment 4 millions d'entreprises
en France qui payent le plus cher donc
on s'occupe upe de ça alors le cette
remise de prix à l'époque il y a 2 ans
ça vous a permis finalement un coup de
pouce financier une meilleure visibilité
nous la la maison enfin parce que nous
en fin de compte on avait deux
casquettes c'estd que la maison
d'entreprise on la connaissait déjà
avant ce concours puisqu'il nous a
accompagné au démarrage de l'entreprise
et un cofinancement en fin compte un
prêtdhonneur qui nous a permis de monter
de créer l'entreprise donc on les
connaissz on avait déjà cet
accompagnement cette première structure
pour nous aider à démarrer parce qu'à un
moment quand vous lancez dans l'entre
prise bah c'est pas toujours simple donc
en de suite quand on a fait le concours
ça nous a surtout apporté deux choses la
première c'est que le fait de faire un
concours vous permet de vous projeter
vous poser des questions faites où j'en
suis où est-ce que je vais où est-ce que
je veux aller donc il y a déjà un rôle
pédagogique rien que de faire le
concours en lui-même est très
intéressant parce que ça vous permet de
vous poser vous positionner et de vous
projeter donc ça c'était déjà le premier
gain il était celui-ci avant même d'être
lauréa c'est celui-ci le premier gain le
deuxième qui a été important pour nous
c'est que c'est un domino qui ont fait
tomber de autres puis plusieurs autres
aujourd'hui la mutualisation d'achat en
France c'est pas ou quasiment inconnu
donc aujourd'hui les entreprises ne
connaissent pas ne savent pas que ça
existe et bien souvent parce que c'est
une arnaque donc faut dire les choses
faut les appeler t qu'elles sont donc le
ce prix là nous a nous a nous a nous a
donné en fin de compte une autorité ça
vient ça rapporte une première
reconnaissance ça permet de donner au
niveau des médias bah d'attirer d'autres
médias aussi et ainsi de suite de
vraiment faire aussi l'effet boule de
neige par rapport à ça et d'avoir
d'autres articles de presse d' mieux
connu et reconnu que ce soit au niveau
du tissu économique local régional puis
après national alors vous vous parliez
donc
d'accompagnement en amont donc vous
étiez salarié vous êtes passé chef
d'entreprise la maison d'entreprise vous
a aidé à passer ce ce cap bah nous on
leur avait demandé c'est ce qu'il
propose c'est déjà un tutora parce qu'on
a une règle c'est pas parce qu'on
devient dirigeant qu'on devient
intelligent sinon ça serait et ça c'est
très important se dire ben il faut
savoir s'entourer s'accompagner le
métier de chef d'entreprise il y a pas
d'école pour ça c'est un moment le vous
l'apprenez sur le tas donc par rapport à
ça c'est important d'aller voir des
pères d'avoir des soutiens des des gens
qui vous accompagnent qui vous
challengent qui vous disent bah faites
pas telle erreur que telle autre donc
c'est aussi ça que nous a permis aussi
la maison d'entreprise et puis on est
allé aussi avec des gens comme par
exemple le MDEF d'aller aussi dedans
d'aller chercher d'autres chefs
d'entreprise de comprendre les erreurs à
ne pas faire c'était ça aussi qui était
très important dans la première
structuration de l'entreprise jean-l
merraud sur sur votre appui aux
entreprises vous pouvez nous en dire un
mot oui peut-être juste un point pour
rebondir sur sur les propos de d'Antony
strcher c'est vrai que dans le cadre du
concours il y a un certain une certaine
enveloppe de de prix qui qui est remise
mais au-delà des prix mêmes je pense
qu'il est important aussi de de de
mettre en avant toute la partie
promotionnelle communication qui tourne
autour des des lauréa et on le voit nous
au quotidien dans dans le cadre des
porteurs de projets que nous nous
recevons nous avons énormément de
porteurs de projets qui à bord d' une
création d'entreprise avec une vraie
technicité c'est que nous avons vraiment
des des projets intéressants sur le plan
technique avec avec une vraie valeur
ajoutée mais on néglige parfois souvent
lors d'une création l'aspect commercial
et pour réussir une entreprise pour
réussir notamment à la développer il
faut savoir surtout vendre un produit
une prestation un service et et je pense
que le toute la la partie communication
qui est développée autour des lauréats
de de de ce concours ben entre dans dans
cette logique et je ne pense pas
qu'Antony strcher me démentirait mais je
pense que c'est un vrai coup de pouce
aussi au niveau de la communication
d'être d'être L'Oréal donc ça c'est un
vrai plus pour pour le territoire de
SaintQuentin t très cher vous m'aviez
indiqué dans un autre entretien il faut
être fou pour monter son entreprise pour
pour ceux qui souhaitent se lancer vous
leur conseiller dirais déjà il faut faut
surtout pas réfléchir aux conséquences
surtout pas faut se lancer c'est quelque
chose de fantastique mais surtout se
faire accompagner et se structurer au
début on est on ne connaissait personne
on était spécialiste dans les achats ça
c'est une chose par contre de structurer
une entreprise d'aller trouver de
nouveaux clients de se la développer de
passer de s entreprises adhérentes à
plus de 3000 actuellement ça se part ça
s'organise ça se structure il faut
surtout pas réfléchir aux conséquences
d'un chef d'entreprise il faut surtout
ne pas être seul et s'accompagner que ce
soit de maisons d'entreprise de d'autres
structures qui viennent vous entourer
elles vont pas créer votre boîte à votre
place par contre elles vont peut-être
vous éviter de faire beaucoup d'erreurs
et c'est ça qui est très important que
ce soit dans des concours ou sur les
financements qui qui est primordial pour
la réussite de sa de sa société osez
être accompagné merci à tous les deux en
tout cas merci à vous